let's taste test the viral chili oil ice
cream and a few different spicy toppings
I don't know how to describe it it
tastes kind of like oily ice cream the
more I eat it the more I kind of like it
like the first bite it's very pleasant
to me a bob two you together chamoy and
tah I think it would taste
great o like a very sour vanilla ice
cream I I would not eat this one again
you're must feeling ooh oh W okay 1 2
three oo m
it tastes like a carry of cream but I
just feel like I ate like pure sauce
sichan sichan you don't like it I do not
like it it feels kind of uncomfortable
Cheers
Cheers oh that's like the first one I
like it how excited are you for this not
at all why is it bubbling all right we
got to go
fast this one's bizarre it feels
unethical